there was a time when the Social
Democrats dominated German politics
those days are long gone now they are
just junior partners in government
dominated by the Christian Democrats and
fewer than one in six Germans votes for
this people's party which is why the SPD
a recently elected new leaders driven by
a more left-wing view of politics and a
deep dislike of the coalition with
Angela Merkel I was and I am skeptical
about the future of this grand coalition
I haven't changed my mind about that
but with this resolution we give the
coalition a realistic chance of
continuing not more not less in 2019 the
party lost votes in every election it
contested and fell behind both the
greens and the far-right alternative for
Germany in the polls which explains why
many of the grassroots are in despair we
need to continue to develop a vision
because ours is the only party that
works through visions and emotions
Helmut Schmidt said that those who have
visions should go to the doctor and I
would say don't contradict Helmut
Schmidt go to the doctor and convince
the doctor the nurses and everyone
sitting in the waiting room so this
party shines as it deserves to carrying
the future in its heart some say this is
not just a German phenomenon but across
Europe social democracy is in retreat
and that's why there is this kind of
feeling in Germany that a lot of things
are changing around people but people
don't see the kind of stewardship the
kind of political leadership that would
gear or you know take take the bull by
the horns and guard into the right
direction so I think what the years but
he needs to do in the
and a half is to come up with an idea
where Germany ought to be in 10-15 years
time but it's now almost 15 years since
an SPD leader was in charge of
government here and with the polls
suggesting the party is struggling to
reach just 15 percent
it seems that few voters want to give
the Social Democrats the keys to this
building anytime soon Dominic Kane
al-jazeera at the German Chancellery